CLASS ACT
>> THE DAILY MAIL IS REPORTING
THAT PAUL ROOF, A PROFESSOR AT
CHARLESTON SOUTHERN UNIVERSITY
WAS FIRED BECAUSE OF AN IMAGE OF
THEM USED ON A CAN OF BEER WHICH
DOES NOT REFLECT THE SCHOOL'S
CHRISTIAN VALUES.
>> NOW, THE --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> AS MAYOR OF THE MUNCHKIN CITY
--
>> Chris: THE BEER IN QUESTION
IS CALLED CHUCKTOWN FOLLICLE
BROWN, WHICH IS ONLY SLIGHTLY
WORSE THAN THEIR FIRST
SUGGESTION, PAUL ROOFY'S SLEEPY
TIME BEER.
>> HERE'S A PICTURE HE POSTED ON
FACEBOOK.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> COMEDIANS NOW THAT YOU HAD A
LOOK AT HIM, I WANT YOU TO NAME
CLASSES YOU THINK PAUL ROOF
WOULD TEACH AT A UNIVERSITY.
>> 60-SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND
GO. DANA.
>> WHICH CAME FIRST, THE CHICKEN
OR THE COPS?
>> Chris: POINTS. GREG.
>> BOO RADLEY WAS GUILTY.
>> FEMINISM: MYTH OR HORSE
(BLEEP).
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> WAFFLE HOUSE ETIQUETTE.
GREG.
>> THE ART OF COUSIN SEDUCTION.
>> Chris: I THINK IT'S JUST
THIS: YOU WANNA (BLEEP).
>> Chris: POINTS. ALISON
>> SPEAKING 'MERICAN? BECAUSE
THIS IS 'MERICA.
>> Chris: POINTS. DANA.
>> ADVANCED BLAMING FARTS ON
YOUR DOG.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALISON ROSEN.
>> INTO HOARDING GUNS FOR WHEN
THE (BLEEP) GOES DOWN.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS. OF
COURSE.
POINTS. DANA.
>> WHERE TO BEAT OFF IN THE
LIBRARY.